Tristan Thompson trolled by fans as he
returns to basketball
amid cheating allegations on Wednesday
night the 27 year old Cleveland
Cavaliers star played the New York
Knicks on his home court just one day
after reports surfaced claiming Tristan
was unfaithful to pregnant girlfriend
Khloe Kardashian with multiple women the
crowd made it clear they're in full
support of the 33 year old reality star
some fans were booing and one held up a
large sign that read and parts we loved
Khloe a source told ET on Wednesday
morning Khloe is completely devastated
by the situation quote Tristan is a man
Khloe built a life with and saw as her
forever Chloe's mother Kris flew to
Cleveland to be with her and support her
in whatever she needs et has also
learned the Kardashian family is
rallying around Khloe as she prepares to
give birth to the pair's first child
together a baby girl and it seems her
besties are as well
Khloe's longtime friend Khadija hack
shared this post to Instagram which
seems to address the drama quote the
best thing a father can do for his
children is to love their mother
[Applause]
you